well hello miss Johanna [ __ ] super daddy
15 years ago yes crazy huh I was only
saying yesterday like what if 15 yes
come on where did it go
what is it like to come back as super
Danny 15 years later it's great because
the demands there you know that was what
was really important for me you know so
many families had been writing into me
when he got to come back and do the
super nanny a format that they were so
familiar with here in the country yeah
I'd left I'd gone off to do other shows
produce other shows lectures writing
books you know but to come back and
actually do the super nanny format the
love on the street I'm taking it all in
I'm just sucking in all that positive
love you know people are really happy
that it's back and I believe it's for
all the reasons that the show stands for
yeah you know which is compassion and
love and empathy and being able to help
families you know and I think whether
you've got kids or not you can relate to
the show mm-hmm
in 2020 where challenges families are
facing now I know you mentioned the
electronic babysitter you know what I
think that parents have overuse
technology to the point that it's
created issues that I've had to go in
and help these families with but on the
other hand you know teenagers are not
feeling so connected as well with their
parents because we're all swiping left
and swiping up you know and looking down
rather than looking up right so you know
technology yes but I think it's
important to talk about mental health I
think it's important to address the
exterior fabric of this country when we
talk about affordable housing affordable
childcare you know certainly paternal
and maternal leave and how financially
that is supported for the family so it
was really taking a look at you know
some of those stigmas some of those
conversations that felt quite awkward or
the media narrative that had not always
been supportive in the past and how we
can talk about those circumstances for
example you know men talking more
emotionally about how they feel
especially when we know that those those
statistics those suicide
to cystic rates are incredibly high you
know that's really scary so you know for
me it was like let's break the walls you
know let's do a super nanny show that
helps every type of family let's talk
about those conversations those Hot
Topic conversations that are happening
now as well as dealing with the parental
challenges of sleep deprivation or how
to couples are going to come together
and really feel like they are doing
their due diligence when it comes to
sharing responsibilities even though
they're both full-time working parents
and the reality of that and the process
of watching me have this experience with
the family it's funny when I started
watching the show initially when I
watched each episode I'm like this kid
is a brad and then you watch five
minutes and you're like no they're not
they just wanted me listen to what can
you tease us with for this season
because I know there's a lot of tantrums
happening there's a lack of
communication there's there are
meltdowns due to not just a child
wanting what they want they're our
parents that are not on the same page
fundamentally and a lot of a lot of
counseling to these families with
respects to their marriage and how they
work together raising kids there are
teenagers that need to feel heard and
are misunderstood there are families
that need to understand and have more
empathy towards those who have
life-threatening allergies and those
that live with addiction and those
families that come from those parents
that live with such there are families
that didn't take kindly to me being
there they wanted me there and when I
was there too got a little bit ugly
oh there's my
yeah come a little bit it wasn't very
pleasant do you think your British
accent
creates Authority for children and
parents there's something about when
used to you do you I feel like your
accent I'm like whatever you say ah
that's my husband please
and I wonder too you know we see how you
you know change these households but
what is your household like and my
household is what is my household like
um it's for the friends children and my
own grandson a supportive husband
friends and family my father and my
dearest friends I like to entertain well
know so it's one or the other it's Eve a
very very peaceful and quiet and a place
for me to recharge yeah and I have a
beautiful space at my muscle space my
home supports what I need my husband you
know my friends always joke that they
feel like they come into a spar for the
weekend if they come to my home sweet
they always say feel so relaxed in the
energy feels great and then it can be
absolutely great chaos because you've
got sticky fingers and kids running
around everywhere and you know cupcakes
and sandwiches and drinks and ice pops
and everything else you know so it can
be like a fun day care nursery right you
know from a place of retreat yeah so
yeah my my home is evil one or the other
really but I do like to entertain as
well so it's nice to have friends around
and I love to cook yeah you know like to
put different dishes you know just
having friends around because I spend so
much time on the road going to different
states of america that when I am home
I'm really conscious at the time you
know I think to myself right okay you
know who haven't I seen before you know
it's six months seven months has gone
past you know the time to connect as
well you know with my husband and for us
to have you know moments that are not
interrupted our time to feed my marriage
you know my relationship you know
and to see my nearest and dearest you
know those that that love and support me
and you know get to hang out with
flip-flops and chilled by the beach yeah
their British accent speaking of Brits
how would you take on the royal family
with all the stuff going on cuz you help
the kids just as much as you help the
adults yes which i think is really
awesome yes what what I will say is that
we have here say we have no facts you
know we have a lot of hearsay so I don't
know the facts and when I help a family
I do like to know facts you know so I
have to really take my hat off to the
Queen yeah you know because the Queen
got everybody together that was
necessary to get together into a room to
resolve you know and it takes the people
that it did to be in that room to
resolve right everybody to be a part of
the solution you know and that's what we
have seen the family do the royal family
do so far right we've seen the Queen get
the relevant parties necessary together
to look at solving write a solution in
respecting what everybody wants and I
think that's important because it's what
I do when I'm helping families you know
it's like how do we all become a part of
the solution and it's about
communication and again that's what our
wonderful Queen has done she's got
everybody in a particular Palace in the
space
I said flit sit down let's hash this out
let's listen to one another let's talk
but that's what I've heard so far you
know but the rest I'm I'm as clueless as
you you know I was raised a little
old-school in the way my I was
disciplined with spanking occasionally
nothing crazy but occasional spank you
so when you say crazy you mean I wasn't
abused I was that's really what people
are saying nothing
it's a good bet every now and then um I
look back on it and feel like I don't
know how else they would have dealt with
me in that situation I have no negative
memories of being spanked I think it was
fine but I know that spanking people are
against it and I understand why because
people take it too far but also the
evidence right what are some of the
effects like we see why it looks crazy
for children but when they become adults
what are some of the advance that
happened I think that's what you again
and I think that's what you're talking
about with knowledge yeah you know
because you've been educated in this
space of being able to read that up not
only do we have the scientific data that
shows that this is it this is an
outdated ineffective practice but you
are very true insane what else would
they have done it's what those parents
knew at the time it's what they were
taught okay and if we probably go back
it probably goes back to some parrot in
time you know however we do know more
today you know we are educated more on
what the impact of spanking for
compliance leads to and there is a very
fine line in this country between those
who say well I was spanked that it
didn't do me any harm and a silent
epidemic here in this country of child
abuse that we need to own we really need
to own and say it exists in this country
and let's all do something together in
this country in being able to help
parents okay so they don't go to what
they knew or auto parenting of how they
were raised right so that the scientific
data that clearly shows that but
wonderful thing about the super nanny
show and what I teach is to show those
parents that when they can choose
alternative measures of not just the
discipline that they implement but what
they need to put in to their
relationships with their children it
creates a healthier relationship where
there's not a push and a pull or a
rebellious
teen or a broken-down fractured
relationship with father and son or
mother or daughter and that is what's
important to me because it is the
yin-yang
it's not about going straight to saying
well how do I discipline what do I do it
should be how do I connect with my child
how do I have a better relationship with
them how do I get on the same page with
my husband how do we both fundamentally
implement what's really important to us
as a couple in how we raise our children
because that is what's going to shape a
better world that is what's going to
allow us to have a society where we feel
more compassion and love